Captain America becomes a Hydra agent
and it's amazing check this out so in
Marvel Comics there's a story called
secret Empire and in this story The Red
Skull uses a Cosmic Cube to rewrite the
entire history of Captain America to the
normal superhero out there he's
basically the same guy he's always been
fighting on the side of Truth and
Justice and everything but the reality
is that according to the new history of
Steve Rogers he was inducted into Hydra
so he's secretly working against the
superheroes the entire time and trying
to find a way to conquer the Earth which
he does the Avengers are basically
defeated they're running on a ragtag
crew somehow they managed to end up
coming out on top but not before Captain
America and a shock to everybody lifts
the hammer of Thor make sure you guys
check the comments for the link to the
full video